merci Fabienne d'être là je suis très
heureux de te voir je suis très heureux
de te voir parce que je t'adore tu es
une femme formidable je vous le dire non
mais vraiment j'ai discuté maintenant de
fois avec Fabienne on adore tu seras
dans une émission de sévide d'ailleurs
oui bien sûr une émission qui a révélé
ma vie exactement bah tu vois ben
j'espère que ça va arriver pour aussi
parce que pour l'instant j'ai envie de
les mettre dans le monastère ou après la
saison 2 franchement si vous pouvez le
faire faites-le c'est génial moi je peux
pas parce que
j'imagine
je dis aussi beaucoup de travail
tais-toi aussi merde
[Applaudissements]
Daniel c'est pas lui ça se trouve
est-ce que ce serait pas lui le mec de
Daniel non
[Rires]
je suis très heureux de toi donc tu
joues ton spectacle né de père trop
connu demain et après demain à 21h à
saint-galmy il faut aller voir Fabienne
qui est exceptionnel non mais c'est vrai
franchement c'est une aventure de dingue
je là je saute dans le vidange ça sera
ma première mes deux premières je suis
et je parle vraiment de ces cinq
dernières années donc l'arrivée de ma
fille je me sens un petit peu débordée
et je le serai demain aussi voilà
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment je suis
presque pas stressée tellement que
tellement que je suis contente de
retrouver je vais raconter quoi le
théâtre je vais raconter alors juste les
cinq dernières années de ma vie je
reprends là où j'ai arrêté et donc je
vais raconter la fin de Plus Belle La
Vie le confinement le fait que j'ai
acheté avec ma sœur qu'on habite
ensemble l'arrivée de ma fille beaucoup
beaucoup de ma fille
quand même j'ai une vie tellement dingue
que j'ai même pas besoin d'inventer je
peux même pas tout dire et vraiment
une vie de maman seule c'est c'est
Hiroshima maintenant c'est fou quoi et
je vais raconter tout ça sans filtre et
bien sûr bien sûr je vais parler du
titre
reconnu j'ai envie d'être là demain pour
moi mais de perdre trop connu pardon
pourquoi né de père trop connu pourquoi
c'est un c'est une faille administrative
et je voudrais vraiment attirer
l'attention de mais c'est vous c'est
vous qui êtes de perdre trop connu ou
c'est ma fille
donc trop connu c'est un jeu de mot j'en
parle beaucoup je raconte j'explique
pourquoi je dis ça mais c'est vrai qu'il
y a pas de cases autre que on passe de
si si le papa n'est pas prêt si ce sont
pas ok pour reconnaître l'enfant et ben
on passe dans inconnu alors qu'on sait
qui c'est le papa et du coup on bascule
dans cette espèce de de violence à dire
que le papa était trop connu pour être
connu exactement pour par par
l'administration c'est ça en fait c'est
ça reconnu pour être connu pas mal c'est
vrai pas mal je te le dis
non mais Fabienne en tout cas je te le
dis Fabienne moi je suis fier de toi je
te jure j'ai pris incroyable
tu te rappelles la soirée qu'on aille
passer tous les deux bah oui on avait
animé un truc tous les deux oui on a
présenté d'ailleurs c'est bientôt le
Global gift exactement
qu'on embrasse bien entendu et donc
ouais c'est rattrapé cette soirée
c'était incroyable je me rappelle ce
qu'on a pu partager des moments
privilégiés ensemble et j'ai eu
l'honneur de présenter cette soirée avec
toi et c'est pas tous les jours soit tu
faisais tout ce qui est toute la partie
anglais toute la partie
anglo-saxonne
ou quoi ah oui c'est comme Jean-Michel
avec les meufs
tu as piqué une vanne à qui oui
parce que ma fille est complètement
insomniaque et donc je lui dis c'est
c'est comme une braise un petit truc un
peu ça se rallume dès qu'elle s'endort
il y a une pièce il me dit tu pourrais
prêter à Koh-Lanta pour les aider à
allumer les feux et du coup j'ai gardé
mais je lui ai dit merci Kamel merci
Kamel qu'on embrasse également il est
19h18 ça vient de Cara est avec nous son
spectacle né de père trop connu ce sera
donc les 20 et 21 septembre donc et bah
c'est c'est demain et après demain un
truc de 21h à Saint-Galmier
Loïc c'est mon graphiste et en fait il a
aussi il fait aussi ma première partie
guitare et j'ai capté tout à l'heure que
en fait là oui c'était Loïc
ça c'est incroyable comment ça va toi
aussi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
parle-moi Fabienne mais tu avais compris
je me suis dit le mec doit s'appeler le
week-end
vraiment le cerveau à l'envers moi j'ai
ça fait longtemps que je le connais j'ai
compris aujourd'hui écoute si tu as
d'autres révélations comme ça tu
n'hésites pas à les faire et on est très
très preneur sache-le mais ouais je m'en
suis rendu compte vraiment que j'ai le
cerveau pas fait comme tout le monde
mais je m'en sors quand même en étant
comédien on s'en sort ça passe on se
rend pas trop con
parce qu'elle est complètement péché
père j'adore elle est complètement chez
père montait heureuse très bon bah très
bien alors ton spectacle s'appelle né de
père trop connu donc on va on va faire
un petit jeu c'est les enfants de star
d'accord je vous montre un enfant par
exemple on va montrer le deuxième pas le
premier parce que je l'aime pas
ouvrier le savoir vous êtes cons comme
des endives voilà donc vous mettrai le
deuxième c'est un fils le fils du
quelqu'un de très connu aux États-Unis
on dirait un
bkhan non non
c'est le fils d'un président il a 80 ans
elle a 80 pige aussi
je l'adore non c'est pas cher
[Applaudissements]
c'est le fils de Madonna c'est le fils
de madonnaie s'appelle Rocco ah oui
c'est vrai
de Lionel
[Rires]
c'est Guy sont à la mode en ce moment
lyrics
exactement regardez regardez alors c'est
toujours aux États-Unis ah c'est le fils
de qui
et ne me dites pas de son père
c'est une très bonne réponse de Valérie
tu réponds de merde de Valérie Benaim
c'est pas du tout son fils c'est pas du
tout
tout je voulais l'affaire qui fait un
instant
en plus
c'est pas du tout lui c'est un mec très
muscléaire
[Applaudissements]
Arnold Schwarzenegger c'est incroyable
la vie d'Arnold Schwarzenegger
sa vie c'est incroyable il a eu que des
coups de chatte c'est incroyable je vous
jure que c'est vrai non mais c'est vrai
c'est un truc de fou mais c'est battu
quand même hein
provoquer la chance exactement
là on retourne en France c'est le fils
d'un animateur très célèbre ah ah
regardez alors là il est apparemment là
il était en boulangerie
c'est qui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
séparément chez l'Office d'un animateur
très célèbre non la gaffe non il a animé
des jeux
dans Paris on l'adore on l'accueille
tout souvent ici Jean-Pierre Descombes
non ah oui ah oui oui
un indice pour les DOM-TOM ah oui ah oui
Julien Lepers c'est le fils de Julien
Lepers
[Applaudissements]
ah regardez ah ouais alors là c'est
encore en France on reste en téloche
regardez
visuellement il lui ressemble
[Musique]
c'est le fils d'une très célèbre
animatrice animatrice qui est dans la
mode
[Applaudissements]
on dirait sa mère qui avait une barre
c'est incroyable j'adore autre fils de
star regardez
regardez hein
c'est le fils d'un des animateurs les
plus connus alors oui non les animateurs
les plus connus en France
[Applaudissements]
on nous a envoyé
sachez qu'il se passait il s'est passé
des choses il y a de ça quelques années
on avait les gars Julien Courbet qui
était chroniqueur dans TPMP
et on a eu un appel aujourd'hui à la
rédaction je vous jure que c'est vrai
aux alentours de 15 heures de quelqu'un
qui nous a dit qu'il était on n'a pas on
va vérifier mais je pense que c'est une
vanne qu'il était le fils cassé de
Julien Courbet et d'une personne ici
Julien Courbet Gilles Verdez il nous a
envoyé sa photo regardez regardez non
mais regardez et nous a appelé il nous a
dit voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
reste avec nous j'aime quand elle est là